Maria's dangerous symptoms were controlled,
and she delivered a healthy baby girl.
And before Maria was discharged from the hospital,
her doctor counseled her again about the signs and symptoms of preeclampsia,
the importance of having her blood pressure checked,
especially in this first week postpartum
and gave her education about postpartum health and what to expect.
And in the weeks and months that followed,
naturally, Maria had follow-up visits with her pediatrician
to check in on her baby's health.
But just as important,
she had follow-up visits with her ob-gyn
to check in on her health, her blood pressure,
and her cares and concerns as a new mother.
This is what high-quality care across the care continuum looks like,
and this is how it can look.
If every pregnant woman in every community
received this kind of high-quality care
and delivered at facilities that utilized standard care practices,
our maternal mortality and severe maternal morbidity rates would plummet.
Our international ranking would no longer be an embarrassment.
But the truth is, we've had decades of unacceptably high rates
of maternal death and life-threatening complications during delivery
and decades of devastating consequences for moms, babies and families,
and we have not been moved to action.
The recent media attention on our poor performance on maternal mortality
has helped the public to understand:
high-quality maternal health care is within reach.
The question is:
Are we as a society ready to value pregnant women from every community?
For my part, I'm doing everything I can to ensure that when we do,
we have the tools and evidence base ready
to move forward.
Thank you.
(Applause)